Please welcome back to the show someone I absolutely love,
Winnie Harlow.
(audience cheering)
(upbeat music)
We finally get to hug in person.
(Winnie laughs)
(audience cheering)
Winnie.
Oh my goodness, a real audience. Wow.
Winnie was kind enough to come to our show
when we were in the height of a pandemic.
And we talked about going out one day
and like doing something-
Which needs to happen.
I know.
We need to make plans.
We've been cooped up for way too long.
Yes.
Way, way, way too long.
I definitely need to be in the Caribbean again,
and just like party on the beach.
Okay, I'll party anywhere with you, including-
Come with me to Jamaica. I'll show you my islands.
Although I feel like I wanna go to your new house.
Will you tell me about it?
So my new house is in California.
I'm really happy.
The selling point for me was the palm tree in the backyard.
I mean, look at this. This is so amazing.
It's my first house, the first house I ever bought,
and I bought it at 26,
which I never thought would ever happen.
Winnie.
(audience applauds)
I can't think of anyone more deserving.
But why did you not think that you would get a house by 26?
Because I think when you're at a certain age,
like coming out of high school
and you don't really know what you wanna do,
it's kind of difficult.
Everyone's kind of putting that pressure on you.
Like, "What are you gonna do?"
My dad was like, "All right, go to the army.
It's like a sure fire away."
And I was like, "That's not my portion in life.
I am not gonna go to the army."
And I started getting these opportunities to model.
And I was like, "You know what?
I never seen myself represented before,
and being able to be that girl
who kids can see on the cover of a magazine."
And I never got that experience is really incredible to me.
And it's empowering to me.
So I was like, "You know what, I'm gonna continue this."
And it's been very fruitful to me, and I'm very grateful.
(audience applauds)
I mean, is it true that you worked with Beyonce?
You know her. Did she take your boots?
(laughs) She did.
She did jack me of my favorite boots once upon a time.
I was on set filming for "Lemonade."
(gasps) Which is the most beautiful.
Body of work
Ever.
Yep. 100%.
So I was on set, and they saw my boots, and they were like,
"Oh my gosh, where did you get those boots?"
Thinking I got them from styling,
but they were my own personal.
And they were like, "We need them for Beyonce."
And I was like,
(audience laughs)
"Take my boots."
Yep.
And I was like, okay, at the end of the day, like,
"Hey can I get my boots back?"
And they were like, "So for continuity purposes,
we actually need them for the rest of filming."
And I was leaving that night.
So I was like, "Okay, cool, no problem.
They were just my favorite boots, but that's fine.
It's Beyonce."
And I walked into my trailer to pack up my stuff,
and there were a brand new pair of way better boots.
So I'll take it.
I got to give Beyonce a favorite.
(audience applauds)
I'm glad that you can both walk in each other's shoes,
literally.
Oh yes.
I never thought about it that way. I like that.
(audience applauds)
I have walked in Beyonce's shoes.
Well, another pair of big shoes in your house
is your extraordinary boyfriend, Kyle Kuzma.
And he was an NBA player for the Lakers,
and now he plays for the Washington Wizards.
Yep.
Perfect.
Mm-hmm mm-hmm.
That must be fun.
Yeah. Very, very fun.
Aw, Lakers.
Aw.
The Lakers and the Wizards game.
Is it true that you are practicing skincare with him?
Oh my God, he's like my Guinea pig.
Oh.
For all new products,
That's so cute.
And he loves it.
He honestly loves it.
He loves having really good skin.
So I like just like sitting him down in the bathroom
and just like doing his skincare,
making sure that he's using his serums
and washing his face properly with exfoliation,
but then also making sure that he's protected from the sun
with SPF.
You have to wear SPF. It's so necessary.
Like you wanna protect your skin
before adding anything to it.
Did you learn that early?
I did because having vitiligo and also, being Caribbean,
one, my skin is really sensitive to the sun,
and I was always in the sun.
So it's like a little rock and a hard place.
Sun care and SPF was always like a go-to for my family,
and my family would always slather me in it.
(bright upbeat music)